why hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today july
21st 2021. do yourself
a favor and subscribe to our youtube
channel tap
the notification bell share our videos
and see what happens you never know
we are doing a q a today we got a whole
bunch of questions at rubinreport.org
but before we get to the questions i
wanted to do one story today because i
don't know if you've heard about
this big tech censorship stuff have you
heard
that the tech companies like youtube and
twitter
and facebook that they don't want us to
really be able to communicate with each
other and that
if they label something that goes
against the narrative as misinformation
they might just delete it all together
and they might do that in coordination
with the government well yeah it's
happening i think you probably heard
about it i'm just talking about for the
for the new people uh well just
yesterday white house communications
director
kate bettingfield was on msnbc that is a
democrat-controlled propaganda network
on your local cable
channel and she was saying that social
media companies should be held
accountable for misinformation this is
completely consistent
with everything that is coming out of
the white house these days as you know
jen pasake or jensaki depending on how
you're feeling
just said last week that the white house
flags
misinformation for facebook so the
government is in cahoots with big tech
and then saki also said that if you are
banned from
one social media site you should be
banned from all of them so this stuff is
escalating rapidly
but i thought this was worth playing
because this is a new
uh player on the field white house
communications director
kate bettingfield we're reviewing that
and certainly they should be held
accountable and i think you've heard the
president speak very aggressively about
this he understands this is an important
piece
of the ecosystem but it's also the other
thing the president has pointed out and
spoke to
when he was asked about this yesterday
is it's it is also the responsibility of
the people creating the content and
again i would go back to
you know there are conservative news
outlets who are creating
irresponsible content that's sharing
misinformation about the
about the virus that's getting shared on
these platforms conservatives
are creating content we can't have
that they cannot go against the
narrative they're spreading
misinformation not misinformation
apparently
when the lefties do it right you know
brett kavanaugh's a rapist
the covington kids are racist russia
collusion
jesse smallett was almost lynched
etc etc you guys get it now putting
aside
the okay we only do this when when it's
republicans who are saying things
uh putting that aside i just thought i
would talk about the first amendment for
a second because you know the first
amendment
does allow for misinformation that's the
thing with free speech
it's not just that it's speech that you
agree with it's speech that you don't
agree with so i would prefer
that we had more people telling the
truth in the public square right i would
prefer that people went
on cnn people went on msnbc across
youtube anywhere that
that communication has had i would
prefer that more people
try to say something true that's what i
try to do here i would prefer that
people not lie i would prefer the people
not manipulate
the facts all of those things the simple
truth is like put it getting the
politics out of any of this regardless
of how you feel about kovid
regardless of how you feel about joe
biden or anything else
the simple fact is that by the very
nature of the first amendment
misinformation
lying it is protected speech you're
allowed to say what you want
in a free society now i say that
actually slightly cautiously because
even by saying that well that's going to
give fodder for the lefties to
eventually attack the first amendment
and there's just simply no doubt that
they will
they don't believe america is good thus
they don't believe that our founding
documents are good
and those bill of rights are attached to
that constitution thing
and they don't believe that that is good
so once you say to them hey
guys you know misinformation is
protected they're going to want to start
carving out some caveats in the first
amendment and that's deeply dangerous so
just i'm just putting that here
as a little marker because i have no
doubt that that's coming but it
is true you are allowed to spread
misinformation and to prove it
i'm gonna i'm gonna make three
statements right now
that are obviously misinformation these
are completely
ridiculous statements and you tell me
whether i should be banned from youtube
twitter
or facebook or have the government come
after me for saying these three things
statement number one and again these are
completely ridiculous
statements statement number one aoc is
smart
that is obviously misinformation that is
obviously a lie that is obviously as far
from the truth as somebody could get and
yet i just said it
misinformation i put it out on youtube
should i be banned should my channel be
blown up should i be thrown into the
gulag
statement number one statement number
two joe biden
doesn't have old person syndrome
he obviously does something ain't right
we all know it the scandal is the
non-scandal and that mainstream won't
talk about it
should i be banned should i be arrested
you tell me
and finally statement number three the
show friends
was funny it wasn't i'm sorry
it just wasn't funny i know i'm gonna
get a lot of hate for that one but
seinfeld way better and you gotta pick
one just pick one okay all right here we
go ruben report q
a uh we got a bunch of good ones and we
mixed it up quite a bit
candice says are there any places in la
fighting back on the reinstated mask
mandate so you know the mass mandate
just kicked in
uh midnight on saturday i was
out to eat on friday it was david's
birthday
and i took the whole crew out and we did
a little virtual reality which was kind
of fun and then we went out to eat
we were obviously not killing people on
friday somehow did if you went out on
saturday and then that
went into midnight you were going to
start killing people um
i did go out once since i mentioned it
on the show yesterday
we did one more birthday dinner for his
actual birthday because his birthday was
on monday
that was the group thing was on friday
yada yada
um and i walked into the restaurant i
was not wearing a mask david wasn't
wearing a mask his mother
his mother wasn't wearing a mask we got
some looks but actually i got a couple
looks of kind of like yeah you're doing
it right man
so i think it's sort of up to every
place and
uh you know look this woman barbara
ferrer i don't know by what authority
she's actually doing this but we know
that the police
the sheriff in la said that he's not
going to enforce this stuff
and the only way let me be crystal clear
about this guys
the only way we get our country back our
cities back our towns back
our lives back our families back and
anything that resembles
anything close to what life was like a
year and a half ago which i'm sure
most of us would gladly do if we could
just do that the only way we get to that
is if we just start living our lives do
what you think you should do
and in my case i i'm just not gonna wear
a mask when i go into these places and
then look if they're gonna
force me to leave i will leave i'm not
there to fight with the security guard
or punch an assistant manager in the
face but
i am going to live my life as a free
citizen in the united states and
see what happens fortunately i don't
leave my house much but
you know what are you gonna do talia
says do you have a special meal
to celebrate going off the grid and do
you have any advice for someone to go
off the grid if they don't have the
ability to travel
so as you guys know i'm doing august off
the grid this will be the fifth year
that i do it
no phone no tv no news no electronics
we're going away for a little bit i'll
do a little beach time
i'll catch up on some reading
not doing much actually we don't have
many plans i'll see a little bit of
family but we're not going to talk about
current events and then
i come back on september 1st uh and
i guess i can announce it now right adam
carolla is going to be uh guest hosting
the reuben report that day
and he will get me caught up to speed
over the course of about two hours on
all of the things that i missed
i've done that with shapiro and glenn
beck and michael knowles
but we thought it would be fun with
corolla this year i think we're going to
do it from his studio
but my main purpose is just to give
myself a little reset it was sort of
like
i was just doing it as a lark the first
time that i did it and each year it's
becoming a certain way harder to do
because i have
more businesses now and my life is just
more hectic and everything else but
that's even
more the reason to do it your question
though is if i have any advice for
someone to go off the grid if they don't
have the ability
to travel man you know just do some home
projects
you know like actually well one thing i
would say for sure is actually lock your
devices in a safe
i am literally maybe we'll take a video
of it but i'm going to hand david my
phone
and my ipad and my computer and he's
going to put him in a safe and lock them
and that's it
that is absolutely it he will have a
phone he goes like semi off the grid
with me
he will have a phone in case there's any
sort of medical emergency we need to
know about or that sort of thing but
having nothing to do with with news um
but i would say if you can't go anywhere
you're just in your house see if you can
do some home projects maybe start a
garden
paint a paint a room do some carpeting
like some stuff
around the house you know we're all
spending more time in our houses these
days for better or worse
and i love doing projects like i really
i've been loving
gardening i like painting i like
spackling i like just doing stuff when i
can do it i like
we've had an ant problem here like i
like getting rid of ants i like just
doing stuff around the house
and and find that and you can almost
have like little little staycation right
there
uh brendan says
scroll the other way michael brendan
says uh
should we start accusing the left of
systemic racism
i hate to stoop to their tactics tactics
but
the constant and predictable dismissal
and demonization of black voices coming
from the right
and the center clarence thomas thomas
soul larry elder is getting so old these
men are some of the smartest in america
and they should be celebrated well
of course i agree with you that those
guys should be celebrated i mean i've
said it before but i think when i look
back on my career
one of the greatest moments will be that
that viral moment that i had with thomas
soul when i said you know what woke you
up
from the bad ideas of marxism and he
goes uh facts
the fact that that went viral i've been
included in thomas soul documentary
since then
millions and millions of people saw that
and i have no idea how many people have
then
read his books and watched his videos
like that i had a little something to do
with that is just
awesome in itself look larry elder i
love larry he's our guest this week
and he's in the middle of this fight to
get on the ballot in the recall he
he is not someone that thought he was
going to be a politician but he's saying
hey
i'm born and bred in la i love
california i want to fix this thing i'm
going to try and do it
so i'm i'm really obviously hoping that
he'll get on the ballot and then we'll
take the fight right to gavin newsom and
just imagine
larry elder like trained debater fact
machine larry elder against evil cartoon
villain gavin newsom
in a in a debate it would just be
awesome but your question about whether
we should really call them racist at
this point
yeah i mean i think we kind of should
there's really nobody
on the right broadly speaking that is
trying to put racism into the system
that is trying to
have policies based on race or keeping
people out of school based on race or
anything
the left is doing that the left is
punishing asian people because they
test highly uh they are punishing white
people because
they want equity instead of equality
they are
modern racists and i i hate to play
those tactics so i completely get the
heart of the question
um but times you got to call a spade a
spade and in terms of
america 2021 they are the racists it's
just true
sam what are you looking forward to the
most when you go off the grid
um you know for me this really it's sort
of what i just said but
it's just this like shut down mentality
it really
is like i try to eat right i generally
try to eat right
i try to you know i try to eat right
anyway but like i really try to focus on
that i try to wake up and exercise every
morning which again i try to do in my
life normally but like i can really
focus on that kind of stuff
i'll catch up on a little bit of reading
but i'm going to spend a lot of days
just staring into the freaking ocean i i
that is fine with me you know a lot of
people
they'll get to the beach and they like
need to do things you need to be doing a
crossword you got to be reading you got
to be texting with somebody and like
i could just sit and stare at the ocean
and have a little fish in the afternoon
and wait till the sun
sun goes down and then have a margarita
and i'm good to go and i just want to
give
like my brain some space to not be
obsessed by
all of this stuff and you know the irony
and i wrote about this and don't burn
this book
is that i do some of these things in my
life as i said with trying to eat right
and
trying to exercise and i don't bring my
phone in the bedroom and i try not to
tweet on the weekends and all these
things
so it's like it's not like i'm fully in
the rat race as much as some people but
we're all in it too much and i would
include myself in that
and uh and the cool thing is as it gets
harder to do each year that's going to
make me want to do it more
each year this year you know we have so
much stuff going on with locals
right now and i'll give you some hints
in my off the grid live stream of the
the last stream that i do on july 30th
before i leave i'm going to announce a
couple things then we'll have some big
announcements the day i get back as well
but so it will be harder too at a
business level but i'm going to figure
out a way
jill says is there anything we
personally can do
to help the cuban people from afar what
can our government legally do if
anything to help overthrow the communist
regime
and or send humanitarian aid directly to
the people bypassing their government so
that's the tricky part right because you
know if you send
humanitarian aid whether it's through a
church or a temple
or an ngo or whatever it might be if the
government is basically guarding the
borders right they're dealing with the
ports and things like that like whatever
aid you're trying to get there most
likely isn't going to them
by the way that's one of the problems in
a uh communist society you know the
government controls everything and when
other people try to bring in ideas bring
in money bring in food bring in supplies
it's usually going to make its way up to
the top and not
actually down to the people because
they're just pretending that they're for
the people they're usually for the
people but it's the people up there
not the people down there i don't know
that there's much we can do right now
other than keep talking about it you
know it seems to have calmed down a
little bit over the last couple days but
to watch
you know in essence the democrats
basically
defend the cuban regime and make this
all about oh this is because of
america's embargo
lift the embargo and then everything
will be okay it's like no
if we lift the embargo then the regime
has that much more strength over the
people
one of the beauties of the free internet
for as long as we have
a free internet if we even have it at
this point is that people are waking up
the average cuban citizen that maybe
was on full information lockdown 10
years ago now has access to the outside
world
and humans believe it or not they yearn
to be free and
uh i don't know so i'm sure you know
what i'm sure some people know there's
got to be some organizations that can
help
you on the ground so if you know of any
please do uh comment right here in the
youtube
comment section and if i see anything
good i'll i'll be happy to share it uh
paige says so dave my 18 year old
daughter just got a
turntable what do you recommend for her
first vinyl
oh well first off we just got a vinyl
record a couple days ago for david's
birthday one of
one of our good friends kelly shout out
to kelly uh
she is friends with john mayer and john
mayer has a new album out it's called
sobrock i think and it's very sort of
80s
um it's sort of like soft kind of
like it's like rock but also like a
little bit of dire straits kind
of sound um it's actually pretty cool
really melodic he does like a lot of
guitar solos it's actually really nice
um so we just got a john mayer vinyl but
i would recommend you
like if you're looking for a vial do
give me like a like a fleetwood maxi if
you can get one of the like original
albums maybe dreams
or or just go with the greatest hits if
that's all you can get i think they sell
them probably at like urban outfitters
or something
and fleetwood mac is just to me they're
they're just the greatest band of all
time you guys know i love sinatra i love
frankie valley all that stuff i like the
crooners
but like fleetwood mac has a band like a
robust band doing like 40 years of work
they've broken up a million times a lot
of cocaine this one banging that one and
but they always pulled it together and
little known fact we got engaged
at a fleetwood mac concert right here at
the forum in los angeles california
jill says what are larry elder's chances
of getting on the ballot at this point
uh by the time uh you're hearing this
right now we may know
we may know right now um another
little-known fact i'm actually
pre-taping this right now today's
tuesday in my world it's wednesday for
you guys but i'm on my way to freedom
fest in south
dakota and we didn't want to not give
you a show on a wednesday um but larry
should have an answer at any moment and
it was very very clear to me that if he
did not
get the answer that he wanted due to
this ridiculous technicality involving
a redaction in one of the tax documents
that included his
social security number that if he did
not get the answer
uh that he wanted that he was going to
be on the ballot alongside the 41 other
candidates
and he's clearly the biggest threat to
gavin newsom right so is it a little odd
that they took the guy off who's the
biggest threat like it's not caitlyn
jenner that's the biggest threat i'm
sorry
um that if he doesn't get on he's going
to keep fighting it so we shall see and
i and i hope he does i just
it's what i said before i just want him
to get to a debate you give that guy
one chance for the debate to throw that
knockout punch and i know he can do it
uh danielle says looking forward to
having you in the midwest dave
have you been there before while you
were there have you set aside any time
to meet
uh or interview the wonderful christie
gnome so i haven't
met christine i would love to have her
on i think we've reached out to her team
a couple times but i would love to talk
to her obviously i'm sure
we'll get her on the show at some point
you know the only time that i really
spent any time in the midwest
was when i was touring with jordan
peterson and we were through iowa and
kansas
and we were in illinois and we were just
bouncing we were in milwaukee and we
bounced all over the place
and it was just great to be in the
middle of the country because uh
i've only you know i grew up in new york
and now i live in california and it's
weird because the things that i talk
about i think resonate more in the
middle of the country so it's very weird
i guess
i grew up on these on these two other
sides of the country but somehow they
they pulled me together
and the things that i believe in and
care about really are nurtured and
cared about right there in that
beautiful center of this great country
uh so i would love to spend some more
time and you know when my neck
my next book comes out which again we're
announcing next week
um there's gonna be a tour and i will
make sure
i make it to the midwest uh geralyn says
how many coveted cases in the texas
democrat circle will it take for the
media to treat it like
it would if it was a group of
republicans do you think the white house
is losing the covet narrative with the
people
this is a great question if you're not
exactly sure what she's talking about i
briefly mentioned it on the show a
couple days ago
a bunch of texas democrats who
basically are against hb3 which is the
the bill
to secure elections in texas okay to
make sure that you have an
id and there's a paper trail and all
that stuff they are protesting
the bill so they went on a private plane
without masks
they went to dc it turns out that four
or five of them have covid
one of them met with the pelosi aide who
now has cove these people have also been
vaccinated so it's like wait a minute
all of these vaccinated people are also
still spreading covered to each other
uh and then i guess one of them actually
met with kamala harris but then
apparently she didn't get it but they
had to rush her to walter reed i think
some of this is unfolding right now as
i'm
as i'm taping this um the answer to your
question though is there's nothing
that could be done that would ever get
the media to treat this as if it was a
bunch of republicans imagine if a bunch
of republicans that were the minority
imagine if a bunch of republicans
um from a blue state
left that blue state flew somewhere flew
to d.c
without masks and then started spreading
covet in dc the media would be calling
the murderers grandma killers baby
killers
racists the whole thing you're barely
hearing this story
barely hearing the story because the
media is just another arm of the
democrat party it just
is all these things these are things
that five years ago
if i said i'd be like oh that's a little
over the top and it's like no
over the top is now the truth brian
allen says i remember
watching a discussion with you douglas
murray a young director and peter
bogosian
is that documentary premiering on locals
and if so when can we expect this
release yes it's called the woke
reformation
and you can go to
[Music]
thewokereformation.locals.com
and you can watch the whole thing and
you can interact with douglas and
peter and the director and it's a really
great
um it's a great piece on just how
to fight wokism because in case you
don't know we've got to find it
it's a big problem uh madison says is
there a group or
grassroot organization you could
recommend for freedom loving people to
join
to help make a difference in the fight
for our liberties
yeah i mean maybe this is going to sound
cliche coming from me but i would say
join prageru i mean they're they're a
non-profit
right so prageru puts up those videos
they get those videos
sponsored so you know it costs a certain
amount of money to
uh to produce those videos and then to
promote those videos and everything else
now i suspect you weren't just talking
about a financial
way of getting involved but one of the
things that are you is doing right now
is they're doing a ton to fight critical
race theory and
they're actually writing documents that
they are trying to give
to public schools so that they can use
an alternative curriculum
curriculum curriculum
uh as opposed to this uh critical race
theory stuff
so they're doing a ton there so you can
you know you can obviously always
uh donate money but you can volunteer
and there's plenty of other
organizations actually this is very
similar to a question that was above
related to cuba
so let's make this comment section all
about how to help people
if you want to help people fight
critical race theory if you want to help
people
uh get you know access to to
maybe food and information whatever it
might be in cuba
go ahead and do that oh and prageru has
a program called prep which is prageru
resources for educators and parents
that's where they're really doing
the the main fight against critical race
theory
and uh you can take part and you know
what maybe we can fix this damn thing i
think anything's possible
uh guys i am at freedom fest right now
i know you're watching me on youtube but
that's the magic of videotape i am
actually at freedom fest right now
i may do some uh some vocals exclusive
stuff while i'm there
so don't forget to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
there will be no direct message thursday
and friday because i am traveling
uh but i think you'll be okay without me
and part three of my interview with
larry elder is up on the youtube
right now and of course the whole thing
is already up ad-free
once again at ruby report.locals.com
okay
ciao